on va revenir sur radio baba est ce que
vous rappelez rabat bien sûr c'était
cette émission qu'on avait fait en
direct ou voilà on faisait une émission
de radio à la télé et on a essayé
diverses choses on va il ya une
information qui est tombée aujourd'hui
selon l'express l'avocat de
l'association le refuge maître pierrât
et donc emmanuel pierrât révèle que la
présumée victime de ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui la sphère du canular
téléphonique n'a jamais existé alors on
va débattre de tous à mantoue vous a
préparé un petit récapitulatif
récapitulatif de la terre si vous n'avez
rien suivi et bien sûr je vous parlerai
je vous dire comment j'ai ressenti les
choses et on va revenir sur toute cette
affaire
juste après ce récap regarde c'est un
ultime rebondissement dans la sphère du
canular jugés homophobes dont cyril
hanouna avait été accusé en mai 2010 est
lors d'un sketch téléphonique dans
l'émission radio baba cyril se faisait
passer pour un jeune homme bisexuels
cherchant l'amour un sketch qui avaient
créé une énorme polémique allant jusqu'à
condamner tpm pays à une amende de 3
millions d'euros à verser au csa en plus
de la désertion de nombreux annonceurs
des milliers de tweets et commentaires
haineux avait alors été posté sur
internet une période difficile d'autant
plus qu'à l'époque l'association le
refuge pour laquelle cyril a toujours
montré son attachement avait lâché
l'animateur indiquant que le jeune homme
victime du canular avait été viré de
chez lui à cause de cette séquence car
ses parents avaient appris son
homosexualité à la télévision très vite
certains médias avaient indiqué des
incohérences et une bataille judiciaire
pour faire le clair sur cette affaire
avait débuté un an et demi plus tard les
choses ont bien changé emmanuel pierrât
avocat de nicolas noguier le président
du refus serait revenu sur cette
histoire
en révélant qu'elle serait fausse et que
ce témoignage n'aurait jamais existé
un bénévole prix dans la folie qui a
succédé à la diffusion de la séquence a
inventé un appel au secours qui
n'existaient pas des propos qui
interviennent très tard après une
tempête médiatique qui a duré des mois
[Musique]
alors je voudrais revenir sur toute la
sphère qui a eu ensuite
ensuite après cette affaire parce que
déjà comment vous l'avez vécu vous
autour de la table parce que c'est vrai
que ça a été un moment très difficile
pour l'histoire de l'émission valérie
moi j'ai très mal vécu parce que je
trouvais que c'était très difficile
d'être accusés parce que on était tous
dans le même bateau donc que ce soit
vous à dominer mais quand c'est vous
c'est nous donc moi j'étais chez moi ça
m'a vraiment meurtrier ça m'a vraiment
blessé qu'on soit accusé de domophobie
parce qu'il s'est quand même un mal
vraiment à dénoncer et je suis vraiment
moi j'ai été très très
résa triste et très très peinés lisa à
moi on l'a vécu superbe douloureusement
en même temps très en colère très en
colère s'il ya une chose qu'on ne
pouvait pas nous reprocher c'était bien
ça en même temps ça nous a soudés et moi
je n'ai vécu mal humainement par rapport
à l'équipe mal professionnellement parce
que toute la presse en parle et moi je
suis une journaliste médias assurant que
j'étais candidat impliqués pour vous en
pensez vous justement c'est un
raz-de-marée médiatique regardez il ya
eu vraiment de pleins d'articles
regarder une à des articles de presse
qui a eu autour de ça derrière ça a été
hanouna nouveau accusé d'homophobie
après à nous à faire comment les marques
interpellé en ligne ont lâché touche pas
au poste puisque il ya eu des sanctions
les annonceurs ont décidé d'alors de
boycotter l'émission ce qui engendrera
12 millions de pertes de recettes
publicitaires pour la chaîne
c'est pas tout puisqu'à ses 12 millions
d'euros de pertes se sont ajoutés trois
millions d'euros d'amendés de la part du
csa
effectivement le mercredi 26 juillet
2010 est le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel
christine kelly a prononcé une sanction
de 3 millions d'euros à l'encontre de
l'émission encore une fois ça fait la
une de toute la presse aussi un pouvez
le voir
regardez plus de 60 annonceurs donc se
sont retirés voilà j'ai eu plein de
messages sur twitter également bien sûr
critiquant les missions et surtout les
fans de l'émission ont même eu peur
qu'on arrête et pmp voilà il ya plein de
gens qui ont été vraiment qu'ils avaient
très très peur je vous faire marrer dans
un instant je vais vous dire exactement
ce qui se passe actuellement
mais jean michel vous comment les
véhicules ce que vous étiez vraiment
avec nous à l'intérieur et exaltant pas
évidemment pas très bien parce que en
plus son nom durant la séquence n'avait
rien vu venir son c'était marais avec
vous voilà d'une séquence on n'avait pas
imaginé que ça puisse prendre une telle
ampleur n'avait pas vu le côté que les
que les gens ont pu voir de polémiques
stériles bêtement d un peu naïvement
jamais de dire je m'étais marea les
séquences pas après évidemment qu'on a
cru qu'il y avait des adolescents qui
avaient été embarqués dans cette
histoire est que ça ne m étais parce
qu'en fait souffert il soit ça a changé
de nom mais d'un an et demi après après
après toute cette affaire donc
l'association le refuge a finalement
reconnu ce mercredi 28 ans qu'il n'y
avait jamais eu d'appel de détresse et
d'adolescents victime dans une enquête
du journal l'express apparemment ignorée
voilà mes temps moi je paye tous les
mois soit c'est le message que savoir
l'avocat de l'association et son
président emmanuel pierrât révèle à
l'express que la présumée victime de
l'animateur n'a jamais existé
bénévole prix dans la folie qui a
succédé à la diffusion de la séquence a
inventé un appel au secours qui
n'existaient pas qu'un bénévole prix
dans la folie qui a succédé la diffusion
de la séquence a inventé un appel au
secours
ces maladies cdc et et c'est surtout que
liddy voilà c'était pas un canular
homophobe mais c'était surtout un
canular bête qu'on sur un nom quoi que
ça c'est vraiment l' affaire qui a
provoqué une onde de choc incroyable
donc donc là ça a été dur pour vous à
vélo st oui et redouane ou
professionnels et étudiants parce que je
vous signale d'ailleurs que j'ai tenu
bon dans vos oreilles
c'est vrai que j'ai refusé de faire des
papiers tendance pour rebondir d'être
dans le mouvement mais vous pensez bien
que ça m'a été reproché par la direction
du tout hein mais par mes camarades mes
collègues
ça m'a été mais très violemment reproché
et donc moi je les ai vécus super de
l'euro et puis avec une espèce de rage
mais moi je trouve que c'est bien de le
dire aujourd'hui mais qu'est ce que
c'est long mais ça comme ça c'est comme
ça et encore c'est vraiment pour
l'instant c'est juste l'avocat de la
victime à l'aide de deux refuges qui a
dit ça s'arrête pas et qu'on était voilà
126 rue alors vous allez pouvoir me
poser toutes les questions que vous
voulez vous aussi chez vous même sur
twitter voilà partout kelly aussi gilles
aussi pouvait te poser toutes les
questions
et moi je vais vous dire qu'elle ait eu
mon sentiment mine de rien sur cette
affaire un an et demi après n'hésitez
pas vraiment j'ai envie de vous parler
ce soir et tout vous raconter hashtag
tpm pays'' a justement qui nous ait
soutenus parce que très sincèrement moi
j'ai l'impression qu'on était
terriblement seul pendant cette période
alors je vais vous dire les premiers qui
nous ont soutenu et je tiens à les
remercier ce sont tous les fidèles de
l'émission
et c'est grâce à vous que l'émission a
pu continuer que l'émission a pu se
relever
les premiers mois je voyais il y avait
plein de gens sur les réseaux sociaux
plein de fans tous plein de fidèles
aussi parce qu'elle est fan zulia aussi
les fidèles et aussi qu'ils regardent
ceux qui regardent tpm paix et pour qui
était pmp certains gros divertissement
et killer change les idées tous les
soirs y'en a pas là c'est grâce à eux
qu'on a pu continuer et voilà donc je
les remercie derrière il ya eu bien sûr
le grand patron qui m'a toujours soutenu
et qui nous les manie toujours voilà de
ne jamais lâcher l'antenne donc vincent
bolloré on a eu également le soutien du
groupe lagardère avec ramzy khiroun qui
nous a beaucoup beaucoup soutenu à
l'époque je sortais d'europe 1 il nous a
beaucoup soutenus et ramzy khiroun a été
de
ce voilà qui fait qu'à mener l'enquêté
mine de rien qui a participé à emmener
l'anc est le patron du groupe lagardère
dont europe 1 et toutes les autres les
autres radios et les gros lots groupe de
presse
il ya eu bien sûr voilà il ya eu
d'autres gens un peu plus anonymes comme
stéphane hasbanian moins bon voila mon
corps mon associé stéphane courbit mais
voilà on était très très seul en tout
cas dans les médias on a été
complètement lâché un sachet le tout
nous a lâché et on voit la joue et où je
vais vous dire un truc tout à l'heure
mais voilà c'est vrai que voilà on était
on était un peu seul mais en tout cas
merci à vous parce que c'est vous qui
avez été notre gros soutiens ici tpm
paix existe encore c'est avant tout
grâce à vous et à vent et grâce à
personne d'autre ben je vous le dis
c'est grâce à vous tous qui êtes là vous
qui êtes chez vous donc merci j'avais
une question un peu bête mais je me s'il
n'y avait pas eu cette enquête de
l'express le refuge aura-t-on du camp
pour le dire et vous savez qu est-ce qui
s'attendaient pour révéler la cause
était de super chiant alors pour
l'instant il ya un jugement qui va être
prononcée
voilà c'est tout voilà donc là ils vont
et c'est ce que va plaider a priori
l'avocat du refuge qu'il ya eu une
erreur voilà ce que vous avez fait un
mea culpa quand même vous avez dit
effectivement j'ai déconné c'est un
sketch pas drôle je me suis planté
j'étais j'ai peut-être blessé des gens
et je m'en excuse mais bon après voilà
si vous savez que c'est très très long
mais l'avocat a dit voile accepté
c'était ce qu'il allait plaider en tout
cas et que voilà apparemment il ya une
erreur au niveau du refuge qu'un
bénévole avait été trop zélé c'est ce
qu'a dit également le président du
refuge web un genre juste à moi c'est
que il faut se remettre dans le contexte
était mise à mort de selena et même
d'une chaîne les conséquences
financières ont été extrêmement
importante vous on a eut concédé à cette
fois ci on le tient le petit rang
valeurs on va on va le tuer donc
effectivement un an et demi après
entendre ça moi excusez moi ça me fait
mal c'est vraiment de l'injustice à 2500
% d'autant des lendemains on avait tous
convenu qu'on s'était pas rendu compte
que c'était une connerie parce que de
mauvais goût mais bon voilà et et
d'apprendre que jo donc aujourd'hui
c'est un faux témoignage se trouve ça
extrêmement grave d'autant plus qu'il ya
un organisme d'état rappelle le csa
pardon qui est sur 7 sur cette émission
est sûre cette accusation fausse voilà
vous vous excusez moi vous demanderez
c'est surtout moi c'est un problème sur
lte ou mois ci au delà de ça c'est aussi
bien sûr comme on dit elise lucet le
disais hier il ya des bons et des
mauvais partout il ya des très très bon
journaliste y en a qui essayait d'être
dans la course au buzz et ils nous sont
tombées dessus sans même enquêté si
j'avais pu je vous dis jean-claude même
aussi qui enquêtent et ramzy voilà
lionel stan et toute l'équipe voilà chez
nous ok enquêter julien lalande et voilà
toutes les équipes ici voilà de ses huit
franchement jamais un journaliste
d'enquêté là dessus c'est ça c'est grave
extrêmement grave willy bernard
oui je sais que cette période a été
extrêmement douloureux pour tout le
monde évidemment et particulièrement
pour vous c'est que vous avez été très
peinés on le voyait tous les jours je
vous voyez votre tête vous étiez très
malheureux cette histoire qui était en
plus fausse maintenant tout le monde le
sait mais à l'époque tout le monde ce
gag à ce que moi qui vous le dis moi
vous allez toujours soutenu en plus le
refuge et vous avez continué à le
soutenir après c'est ça qui est dan
alors quel message avez vous devriez
vous de le redire alors moi je vais moi
je vais vous dire le message qu'ils ont
envie de dire que j'ai envie de deux
voiles de clamer ce soir c'est que je
sais qu'il ya plein de gens voilà je
vous le dis et j'ai commencé à le voir
sur les réseaux sociaux qui commencent à
critiquer le refuge
il faut par commence à dire du mal du
refuge et qu'il y voilà cette
association c'est une association de
mire avec ça vraiment les chéris je vous
le dis même si vous m'aimez et si vous
m'aimez ne le fait pas parce
qu'aujourd'hui le refuge on a besoin il
ya plein de jeunes garçons et de jeunes
filles qui ont besoin du refuge ils font
un travail exceptionnel
cette histoire je pense qu'elle a
dépassé un petit peu tout le monde même
le président du refuge contre qui je
n'ai rien du tout voilà je vous le dis
et ce qui est dingue si je vous dis la
vérité c'est qu'après cette histoire on
a continué à se parler avec nicolas
noguier à s'envoyer des coeurs et
m'appeler son grand frère maher et son
petit frère il m'a toujours dit tu étais
mon petit frère cyril comment tu vas
tout ça et j'ai toujours dit voilà je
serai toujours là pour toi
il n'aurait malgré ce thème ce qui s'est
passé je serai toujours là pour le
refuge vraiment moi je ne leur en veux
pas du tout ce qui m'a peiné moi à la
base dans cette histoire c'est qui est
plus avoir une victime mais qui peut
avoir quelqu'un qui a vu sa vie basculer
à cause de nous à cause d'une connerie
qu'on avait fait à la télévision en
direct comme dit c'est un sketch con
mais c'était pas un sketch homophobes et
qu'ils aient pu avoir quelqu'un qui soit
mis dehors de chez lui à cause de cette
affaire et qu'ils soient mal à cause de
nous moi pendant un an et demi je vous
lis j'ai pensé qu'à une chose c'est
retrouver
victime non pas pour dire le refuge a
menti c'est juste pour retrouver cette
personne essayer peut-être de l'aider et
essayer d'aller voir ses parents
peut-être d'essayer de voir ce qui ce
que je peux faire pour l'aider et on n'a
pas retrouvé cette personne on a mis
tous les moyens en oeuvre pour retrouver
cette personne et on voit aujourd'hui à
99% récents laissent un goût reste
encore dans le conditionnel sept
victimes n'existaient pas qu'elle aurait
été inventé et c'est pas un soulagement
pour moi de dire aujourd'hui je suis
content je vais claironné j'ai gagné en
juillet ils m'ont fait passer pour ce
que je n'étais pas le seul truc qui
m'intéresse c'est qu'aujourd'hui donc ya
pas eu de victimes et c'est juste ça qui
m'intéresse aujourd'hui de savoir gagner
un dernier truc c'est que le refuge
continuer à aval à soutenir le refuge je
continuerai à le soutenir comme je lé
fais même après la ferme ça fait un an
et demi que j'ai pas lâcher de refus je
pouvais demander à l'ats son président
je les tue le temps voilà j'ai et je ne
les lâcherai pas et je les lâche quand
comment et surtout vous ne les lâche et
par oui